the history of the borg warred Hanza
kept Mila convertible as as old as the
history of the Federal Republic of
Germany and it looks like it's just
driven out of a film from the post-war
years then there's that old fashioned
metallic knocking sound of the 52
horsepower engine our test driver says
he's driving a real luxury car aboard
vardhaan of 1500 built in 1951 the
glittering gold of the steering wheel
and instruments transport him back to
the heydays of the West German economic
boom the Beauregard was a bit of a
miracle in post-war Germany when it was
introduced at the Geneva Motor Show in
1949 the hands of 1500 blew the
competition away Opel Ford and Mercedes
were still showing cars based on pre-war
models from the 1930s the honza's engine
was superior to the sleek four-cylinder
motor boasted 52 horsepower whereas the
Mercedes 170 v could only manage 45
officially this vehicle has a top speed
of 120 km/h our test driver says but to
reach it requires lots of time a nerve
because the car is hard to handle
because it lurches around so he only got
up to around 80 and that was enough
on the other hand the rear swing axle
which makes the car so hard to handle
also ensures a surprisingly comfortable
ride Christophe Bauer says visually it's
like having the back of a whale in front
of you from this vantage point people
might think the car is huge but that's
not so the Hansa was produced as a sedan
a station wagon a box van and even as a
four-door luxury convertible with a hate
Nuala car body like this model from the
incite House Museum in wolf's poor
Krista very quickly picked up on the
car's biggest weakness its transmission
he says having the shift on the steering
column the height of modernity in the
1950s doesn't make things easier as
there's no direct access to the gears
and patches and jerks but when it works
it works yes
23000 Hans at 1500 s were built over the
course of three years there's something
almost stately about driving a
Beauregard Hansa 1500 Christoph says but
in 1949 this car was absolutely
state-of-the-art it was the first German
car with an american-style pontoon body
still he knows that it's very simple
with little in the way of chrome and
trim but the technology was very modern
independent suspension electric turn
signals and starting in 1950 the first
German made automatic transmission the
Hans amat Atlantic however Christoph
says that the VW hey Beulah looks much
younger fresher almost eccentric even
though it uses much older shapes car
body manufacture hate Merlin transformed
the VW Beetle into an iconic convertible
with its coquettish rounded back
completely retractable roof an elegant
two-tone paint job the mass-market
vehicle was now a luxury car but with
its 25 horsepower engine remain down to
earth
it seems to suit Christophe better than
the blog vodka just two new models were
marketed in Germany in 1949 the
voluptuous Borg bard and the Schick hate
murder convertible
they were the colourful cars of their
day in comparison to the bar guard
Christophe says this VW drives in a
wonderful manner that's almost lively
and sporty he says back then there were
people who loved the extravagant and so
Hitler was contracted to build two
thousand of these convertibles they
build just 696 though because their
production facilities burned down in
1949 this tragic event has made the VW
hate Mila convertible into a much
sought-after collector's item that sells
for the price of a Ferrari just 100 of
the convertibles are still around today
Cristo says just like with a Borg vard
the VW also wanders around on the road
it's narrow tires and rear swing axle
mean that you really have to concentrate
to keep within the lane went out for a
drive it's best to take the advice of
beetle developer fed non portion and
just let the 1.1 litre four-cylinder
engine
rejoice from 0 to 150 seconds
not exactly a sports car he exclaims the
car can only reach 105 kilometers an
hour but he says that doesn't matter
with the wind in your hair you feel
you're travelling fast in its day the VW
hate murder costs 7,500 darts three
times as much as a normal beetle the
Hansa convertible sold for almost 11 and
a half thousand marks christoph says if
he had to choose between the two hate
merlin convertibles he'd take the VW
because it handles better and he loves
its shape he says the instruments are a
bit more reserved in Spartan but then
again he prefers understatement
for this day both hate Merlot
convertibles are still dream cars and
that's no understand